our people seeing the little screen or
the big screen because I see myself
twice I see a long screen and a small
one word just the big screens alright
guys bang-bang I have the one and only
mr. Peter Schiff here he is going to
educate us on the economy he's been
yelling and screaming about this stuff
for the better part of a decade and
you've been right sir
so thanks so much for coming on and
talking about all this sure and you know
a lot of things are gonna happen because
there's a lot of other predictions I've
made that haven't come to fruition yet
but they're all it's all gonna happen I
mean it's what's happening now is just
you know part of it all right so let's
go all the way back to 2008 that
financial crisis and just give us an
overview of the things that you saw and
kind of what you were really calling for
at the time in terms of the structural
issues in the market and why the
quantitative easing and the monetary
stimulus didn't allow for the correction
of the market at that time yeah we'll
try to you know give a kind of cliff
note version of bad cuz it's a it's a
pretty long question and I've you know
I've answered it on a lot of different
things in fact I did a three and a half
hour live YouTube a chat yesterday and I
kind of touched on some of that there so
people can go and you know to go to my
youtube channel or Schiff radio I put it
up on my podcast this morning and people
could could listen to that if they have
more time but basically so we have the
dot-com bubble pop and and that was
fueled by Fed policy and artificially
low interest rates and and things like
that at Greenspan had and we had a
shallow recession that was truncated by
the Fed the Fed cut interest rates to 1%
and that prevented the recession from
running its natural course it kind of
short-circuited it so stocks and real
estate never really finished going down
because the Fed intervened and propped
him up and a lot people think well
that's a good thing but no because
alright guys I think he is a internet
connection may have fallen out there
let's see if he can come back here in a
second okay yeah so we exacerbated those
imbalances by cutting rates to 1% and so
by doing that the Fed yes made the 2001
recession shallower than it otherwise
would have been but instead of the
benefits of a recession that kind of
claims the problems in the economy and
laid the foundation for a real recovery
we got a recovery based on a housing
bubble and I knew that this was very
unsustainable I knew that there was
going to be a big financial crisis when
real estate prices ultimately fell which
they would all bubbles pop and I knew
that when real estate prices went down
unlike when stock prices went down which
was more a function of the individual
owner I mean most people didn't borrow
money to buy stocks I mean there was
some margin buying but most people you
know they bought stocks with their own
money but they bought real estate with
somebody else's money and so I knew that
when real estate prices fell and
mortgages defaulted that it would become
a financial crisis because the lenders
would be in trouble and I knew that a
lot of the loans have been extended with
minimal to no down payments and there
was gonna be very little if any equity
left in the homes for the collateral but
I also knew that unlike the stock market
a lot of people were using their real
estate their houses as an ATM machine so
a lot of cash it out refire enabled and
so there was a lot of consumer spending
that really never should have taken
place it was only because people thought
they were richer than they were and
somebody was willing to lend the money
against their house to go and buy a car
or take a vacation or do whatever they
were doing and so I knew that when real
estate prices collapsed and all the home
equity disappeared that all the consumer
spending would go along with it
disappear and so I knew we would have
the worst recession since the Great
Depression that we'd have double-digit
unemployment trillion to our deficit so
I wrote about it I talked about it and
then everything I forecast happened
including
what I said the government would do
about the financial crisis you know
because I knew it was coming I said that
they would make the same mistakes that
caused it they would slash interest
rates and print a bunch of money and try
to reflate the bubbles the only thing I
got wrong is that they didn't try to
reflate the bubble they succeeded and
the bubble got much bigger and now that
bubble is popped finally and they are
attempting to reflow and I said the
minute the Fed tried to normalize rates
and shrink their balance sheet in fact
even before they tried it when they just
talked about it I said that this bubble
is so big there's no way that you can
you know take the air out of it so I
said if the Fed ever tried to normalize
rates they would be back at zero if they
ever tried to shrink their balance sheet
they would have to reverse the process
and those forecasts have come true the
Fed never got to normal we got to two
and a half and now we're back at zero
the Fed never shrank its balance sheet
very much in fact today the balance
sheet is bigger than it's ever been and
it's headed for the moon people are now
talking about ten trillion to our
balance sheet I was talking about that
years ago now people are talking about
it today we're gonna get there probably
even faster than I imagine we would but
the reason I knew the Fed could never
normalize rates for shrinking spouse she
just because I knew that instead of a
recovery we had a gigantic bubble and as
soon as the air started coming out they
would desperately try to refill it but
the crisis bare with us for a second
guys is a connection we'll come right
back
it's given one minute Peter is down in
Puerto Rico so the internet connection
may not be the best stick with us for a
second he'll come right back I believe
Peter still on but I don't know if Peter
can actually all right can you see me
Peter
all right he's coming back in this is
what we get for a great price of an
education you got to be patient for a
second all right there you go so I don't
know why we keep losing it but so as I
was saying we're now at the point of the
real crash because they are gonna try to
reflate the bubble so they're doing
everything they did after the financial
crisis only got a much bigger scale
because this is a much bigger financial
crisis because we have a lot more debt
now in fact they keep trying to deny
that it's a financial crisis of course
it's a financial crisis the banks would
have already failed if it wasn't for
what the government is doing but this
time they don't want to just bail out
the banks they want to bail out
everybody the entire nation is getting a
bailout i they're printing money like
crazy but they don't realize that when
they did it the last time it didn't work
it was a failure
that's why they're doing it again but
they've got a false sense of complacency
because when they did it before all the
inflation that they created went into
the stock market went into the real
estate market so these guys think that
they can get away with that again it's
not gonna happen this time this time
it's going into the supermarket this
time you're gonna see run away maybe
hyperinflation
I think hyperinflation as bad as that is
I used to think that was a worst-case
scenario now it's kind of the most
probable it's not a guarantee you know
but in order to avoid high
for inflation things are gonna have to
get really really bad but you know I
think we're gonna go through something
in this country
unlike nobody in this country has
experienced it I mean they've
experienced it in other countries you
know Argentina Venezuela Zimbabwe you
know other countries have gone through
hyperinflation this we have it but what
we're gonna go through is gonna be much
worse than what people went through
during the 1930s during the Great
Depression because you know money gained
value during the 1930s we're gonna
destroy the value of our money and you
know I mean it's who I mean everybody is
excited about the government taking care
of everybody in the government providing
everybody with stimulus checks well I
mean those stimulus checks aren't going
to matter if there's nothing to buy the
money that they're printing doesn't have
any purchasing power that's where we are
right now you know I mean everybody
thinks the government can take care of
the people when the government doesn't
have any money that doesn't first take
from the people and it's not good if
it's not gonna take it from taxes if
it's just gonna print it into existence
which is what we're doing then you're
simply destroying the value of the money
there's no free lunch
all right people keep talking about
World War two and it has to be like
World War two yeah in World War two the
government didn't bail out the people
the people bailed out the government the
government raised taxes dramatically to
fight World War two the government
borrowed money from the people during
World War two and then after the war
ended the government paid the people
back what they prob so now it's the
opposite the government is broke the
people are broke so I mean you know how
is it broke government gonna bail out a
broke nation they can't so that but they
think that the money they print has
value it doesn't they're about to find
out I mean I you know I think the
dollars gonna collapse once this
liquidity crisis is over short-term
liquidity which is causing a rush into
dollars which is what happened during
the financial crisis early in the Oh a
financial crisis the dollar went up but
then it got killed and the only reason
it stopped falling was because everybody
believed because the Fed convinced
everybody that QE worked and then zero
all right Peter come right back I'm
willing to bet easy to come back faster
this time cuz he figured out what he's
got to do when when he gets kicked off
just wait a second and he will reappear
like magic this is the type of internet
connection you must get when you use
gold to buy it there we go you're back
alright keep going so I guess everyone
oh the last night you heard that they
convince everyone QE what that they
convinced that was a long time ago well
they convinced everybody that it worked
because they said they were now gonna
end it they were gonna normalize rates
and shrink the balance sheet back down
to where it was before and I never
believed that I said it was impossible
but Wall Street believed it and but no
one's gonna believe that now I mean
they're not even gonna pretend that
anymore so once the dollar starts to
fall it's never gonna stop you know the
price of gold is not gonna stop rising
you know during the financial crisis the
initial liquidity crunch caused about a
25% drop in the price of gold which you
know the stock market lost half its
value so gold didn't do as bad as the
stock market but within about six or
seven months gold made a new high and
then it kept going and didn't you know
it went up to almost 2000 the high
before the financial crisis was maybe
like 1,100 and it went down at 8 late
hundred or something this time
gold only fell about 15% and it's
already recovered almost all of its
losses from the peak it's only about
another 2 or 3 percent away from its
high and it's only been you know a week
or two so this shows you how much bigger
the current crisis is and how much more
reckless the Federal Reserve and
Congress's stimulus and bailouts are and
how much more destructive I mean even
though the dollar index has rallied you
know we didn't rally much we rallied a
few percent I mean it went the dollar
index during the financial
Oh eight went from 71 to like 104 so
this time it went from about 98 to about
100 and 200 you know so not much of a of
a dollar move but there come on Peter
better get them back here it's that
Porto Rico Wi-Fi I don't know why this
is such an unstable connection it's cuz
you got Puerto Rican Wi-Fi come on
you're in Puerto Rico join the Sun oh
you think it's a Puerto Rico I mean I
don't have any problems on some other
things but anyway maybe it's all the
solution what what happens in a world
where the Federal Reserve does what we
all think it hit it's going to so they
are gonna end up printing trillions of
dollars here one do you think that's
actually what they're gonna have to do
and then to what does the world look
like you know five years from now if
they go ahead and do that well I think
this is really the final stage of the
end of the you know dollar dominance as
the global reserve currency I mean the
Federal Reserve yesterday did something
that I also predict they would do a long
time ago is that is go to QE infinity
and not only QE infinity for the
Treasuries and mortgage-backed
securities but they're now adding muni
bonds corporate bonds so the Federal
Reserve is gonna be buying the entire
dollar that I'm in a bond market because
the only way they can keep interest
rates so artificially low is to lend all
the money themselves because no private
lender is dumb enough to make a loan
with a negative yield a negative real
yield after inflation and I think what's
gonna happen is this is gonna be a mass
exodus out of the dollar
I think foreign central banks are gonna
take advantage of the feds bid to sell
all their Treasuries to the Fed so the
Fed is going to be buying all the
Treasuries from around the world and all
the dollars and what our central bank is
going to do with the dollars that they
get when they cash in their Treasuries
they're gonna buy a lot of gold
gonna do because they're gonna have to
hold something else as a reserved for
their fiat currency because before
everybody was using the dollar all these
foreign central banks were holding gold
that would every time he starts to get
excited he's gonna get kicked off if you
could get super frustrated he'd be right
back though think of these as commercial
breaks maybe I'll start throwing in
advertising when when he drops off so
let's give him a second here and it'd be
right back all right you're back so
central banks are all buying gold well
they're gonna buy gold I said before
before we went off the gold standard or
before Bretton Woods the central bank's
backed their currency with gold and the
United States you know after the war
Second World War we convinced the world
to back their currencies with dollars
instead of gold but it was easy to do
that because the dollar was as good as
gold because if you had $35 you could
get an ounce of gold just you ask the
government for it and they would give it
to you and it was an it was one that was
the exchange rate 35 paper dollars for
one you know ounce of gold and and so
that worked but in 1971 because we had
printed more dollars than we had gold
and foreign nations like France were
coming to the United States with their
dollars and asking for their gold and we
didn't have enough then we defaulted on
that promise and the dollar had a major
devaluation because bull went from $35
an ounce to 800 right and then but the
dollar continued to function as the
reserve even though it was no longer
backed by anything so basically other
fiat currencies were backed by a fiat
currency which meant they were backed by
nothing but the world continued but
because we had this privilege of just
printing paper money that people would
hold in reserve we had all this seniors
gain from our status and so America
began to live beyond its means and we
developed an economy that is based on
consumption and imports and borrowing
and we don't save enough we don't
produce enough and all this has been
sustained by the world who has supported
us by accepting our IOUs and and not
cashing them in and and so the world has
had to support the United States so
America gets to live above its means and
that means the rest of the world lives
beneath its to make that pop so voila
while we're waiting for Pierre to come
back go check out block 5 you can go to
block 5 calm slash pomp you can go
deposit crypto or G USD USD C you can
earn up to eight point six percent APY
Peter will come right back but you
actually better nope just keep going
you're killing it I'm running ads when
you drop off I'm gonna start running ads
yeah it's so central banks are gonna buy
gold to replace the dollars that there
are no longer holding in reserves and US
Treasuries and you know these central
banks used to earn interest on their
Treasuries that was another reason that
they held them well they can't hurt any
interest now so they might as well just
hold gold and and so Gold's gonna be
romana ties and it's gonna you know and
I think so five years from now to the
sense that this has happened the world's
gonna be a much better place I mean
outside the United States because the
world is not gonna have to support
America anymore and we're very expensive
habits to support so I think you're
gonna see an increase in the standard of
living in particularly in a lot of the
emerging markets that have been doing
the lion's share of the heavy lifting
they've been having the big trade
surpluses with us and they've been you
know loaning us their their savings and
so um so that's gonna be a big plus for
people who are living in other parts of
the world so how do stasis complete can
we simply just put the dollar back on
the gold standard would that solve the
problem well the dollar will be back on
a gold standard eventually I mean that's
the only solution but there is no
solution that is painless
that is the problem right there's
nothing that we could do that's going to
change the reality of that the fact that
as a nation we're broke so we're gonna
have to come to terms with that and the
government's gonna have to tell the
public instead of like we're gonna take
care of you like they're saying now we
you're on your own we can't take care of
you so and a lot of people think that
the government's gonna support them in
their old age they're not a lot of
people think the government's gonna
provide them with health care they can't
right so we're going to have to all
right while waiting for Peter to come
back
unstoppable domains dot-com / browser
you can go and download their new
browser and you can start to access the
decentralized web unstoppable domains
com / browser Peter we'll be right back
I'm here alright go ahead
hello yeah so I said it you know it's
gonna be very difficult to rebuild the
economy but it'll be impossible if we
increase government I mean the real risk
is that America becomes a complete
totalitarian type socialist country
that's you know that's the direction the
pendulum is slain to swinging and I do
believe that when we have this massive
crisis we have runaway inflation which
is going to start with price controls
and then you know rationing and you know
shortages and long lines and black
markets and all kinds of things but you
know as things get really bad
capitalism is gonna get the blame
greedy businesses who are raising prices
are gonna get the blame you know so I
don't know I mean if America could be a
very very dark place five years from now
it could be very very I mean much worse
than now I mean you think it's like out
of a out of a movie now like this is so
surreal and kind of apocalyptic that
nobody wants to go outside it's gonna be
very different when you know you can't
go outside because it's not safe because
people are rioting and you know so it
looked things could get really really
bad I mean it's you know we are gonna
destroy the currency and you know that's
that's a very dangerous thing to do
I mean it's it's it's worked out
horribly you know in other countries but
you know there's a big hubris out there
now that we got away with it last time
we can get away with it on an even
bigger scale this time we can just print
money we could mint trillion dollar
platinum coins we can we can load up
digital wallets with digital dollars and
just start giving people money to spend
like just create it out of thin air look
we can create all the paper money we
want but we can't create purchasing
power we can't create the products in
fact this is the crazy thing about all
right well we're waiting for Peter to
come back tack spit calm they'll help
you pay your crypto taxes go to tax bit
comm slash invite slash pump again tax
bit comm slash invite slash pop and get
your taxes paid just do this on a
telephone now come on let's go well I
would have finished when I was just
Saylor B all right good let me finish
what I was saying though because that
this coronavirus because people are
quarantined and not working the supply
of goods and services available is going
to diminish right so there's gonna be
less stuff to buy at the same time the
government is creating more money to buy
it so you're gonna have all this cash
and fewer goods and services to buy so
it's like we're getting the that the C
price is going up on both ends we're
getting a decline in supply at the same
time that we get an increase in demand I
mean right now we're getting a little
bit of an increase in a decrease in
supply and energy or or in demand
because nobody's flying around but you
know as all the US oil companies the
shell companies go bankrupt and start
and stop drilling and then when the
dollar goes up and all of a sudden the
emerging markets start importing more
oil oil prices are gonna go way up and
Americans are gonna be stuck you know
paying through the nose what currency
ends up taking global reserve status if
the dollar fails
well no currency I already said that so
I don't think the world is just gonna
joint another reserve currency remember
the only reason the dollar became the
reserve currency is because it was
backed by gold there are no currencies
today that are backed by gold I don't
think it makes sense to put the crown on
the euro or the N or the Chinese either
RMB so I think the most logical choice
is just to go back to what worked before
it was the dollar and that's gold and
and that way you know every it's all
fair nobody can print gold you know gold
is mined out of the ground it's a real
commodity it represents actual work you
know we're waiting for Peter to come
back go check out crypto calm you can
buy sell earn invest in lend on crypto
comm they've also got a mobile app
crypto calm they've been longtime
supporters of the show so go check them
out it's a it's a perfect store of value
and it's a perfect monetary unit so that
you know that that's where we're headed
you know now I know you know and so a
lot of your mm-hmm good yeah I know a
lot of people that you know that follow
you are thinking no no this is where
Bitcoin comes in right like Bitcoin is
gonna be the new medium of exchange it's
gonna be the new store value it's gonna
new be the new money and I don't think
there's a chance of that happening I
just don't I don't see any central
bank's deciding that they're going to
use Bitcoin as their reserves it's just
it's no banks have Bitcoin on their
balance sheets now they have gold
there's no precedent for using a digital
currency and it doesn't have the the
physical properties that gold has that
gives it value to store and so I don't
see that I don't see individuals
flocking to crypto currencies either I
you know I just don't see people
transacting in Bitcoin it's too
unreliable unstable volatile you know I
just don't see that happening at all I
mean it's a bunch of wishful thinking
out there people just think they're
gonna own these bitcoins and they're
gonna be
super-rich because they have a few
Bitcoin or a fraction of a Bitcoin
whatever they got but I think it's just
a pipe dream I think bitcoins gonna
collapse as well as lot of these fiat
currencies probably morges Bitcoin could
go to zero or close enough to it that
you know might as well be but no and I
think I wouldn't worry when we go back
money one of the reasons that people
want let me finish this one of the
reasons that people want Bitcoin is
because the current monetary system is
flawed and I agree anybody who you know
thinks the monetary system is flawed and
there's gonna be a crisis and they've
bought Bitcoin I agree with them that
there's gonna be a crisis we're waiting
for Peter to come back make sure you go
check out ledger they've got a whole
bunch of hardware solutions to help you
keep your Bitcoin and crypto safe you
can head on over and check out ledger
they are a recent sponsor podcast I'm
back but once once once we have a sound
or monetary system based in gold again
then the case for Bitcoin won't be as
strong because now we'll have a sound
monetary system you know yes you're
still be all this government
surveillance which I don't like but the
problem is you really can't get around
it with Bitcoin unless you're totally
underground but even then you know the
government can track what's going on on
the internet so I don't you know unless
you're just you know physically handling
handing somebody your you know your your
seed seed phrase on a piece of paper you
know they're gonna you know if you're
doing anything online with Bitcoin
you're creating a you know a digital
trail that they could follow what do you
think of happens to the traditional
currencies will we see digital fiat
currencies meaning a digital dollar a
digital one a digital ruble etc or do
those currencies never actually get to
be digital well I mean in most if
they're actually digital now I mean most
of the money that the Federal Reserve
creates is digital it's not you know
it's not a bill that the actual physical
cash is a small part of the money supply
so in a way we already have that but
yes and in fact they're even talking
about that now it's in one of these
stimulus bills as they basically they
will allow digital dollars to be created
that are one-to-one with the physical
dollar and you can spend those and they
would be liabilities to the Fed they
would be on the Fed's balance sheet just
like cash except it would be digital
cash and I think that's actually gonna
be a bad thing for the people because
now the government has complete control
over you because they know every all the
money you have they know where it is and
they know how you're spending it and
they can micromanage your spending they
can deny you the ability to use it for
certain things or certain products I
mean I mean they and they know
everything you buy so yeah I mean that's
you know they could just outlaw cash and
and you know just have everybody using
digital cash but yeah they could do that
but again remember the podcast is not
only a podcast I write a daily
newsletter every single morning you can
go to pom-pom stack comm and check it
out pomp sub stack comm Peter we'll be
right back
or maybe he won't come back we'll see
he may eventually just give up or maybe
his power went out like Caitlyn long
this is what happens when you move to
Puerto Rico he has completely
disappeared on us I think one of the
things that's interesting what he's
talking about here is there's absolutely
a trade-off between Trish up there is
all right go ahead we can't hear you now
what happened can't hear you
yeah check your settings oh no
everything everything looks sunny hey
why I don't know why you can't hear me
go I'm talking you can't hear me I can
hear you now oh whoops hey but what's so
funny
chopping the computer you Moni laughing
huh
it's a professional operation here yet
me dropping your computer like that yeah
well look I'm at my house but anyway
well as I said but you know it isn't say
what you should do see you you know you
you you know that you you understand the
problems with the Fiat monetary system
you understand the problems with
quantitative easing and zero percent
raids and and you know there's a big
crisis coming but unfortunately you know
you're steering everybody in the wrong
direction that's the problem you got you
know you got you can't make your
followers go broke so they have nothing
to save you know I mean you got it you
got to get him into real money you got
to get him into gold right and you got
to get him out of Bitcoin beat you know
beat be the guy that gets out don't be
the guy that goes down with the ship you
gotta happen I don't me you got I heard
you gotta have your network with Bitcoin
listen I don't disagree that Gold's
gonna do well coming out of this but I
also think that bitcoin is going to do
much much better than gold just because
it's more volatile on the increase of
quantitative easing both gold and
Bitcoin will do well but how do you just
do better how do you know that based on
what what if it what if it just goes
down well what it has it done for the
last 11 years and what this structure is
actually more provably scarce than gold
and it's easier to use than gold it what
it's done for the last 11 year how do
you know the last 11 years
was it a bubble you don't know that you
I mean it started out very obscure as
like kind of like a game
for libertarians and things like that
and you know it didn't really start
attracting investor attention until it
really moved up to about a thousand and
then it pulled back and it stayed at two
three hundred for a few years and then
all of a sudden everybody rushed into it
and it went up to twenty thousand now
it's it's sixty six hundred you know
almost three years later to me that
looks like a bubble that peaked I don't
see how you can you know know for sure I
mean you could guess that maybe this is
that that move up to twenty thousand was
just another move similar to the moves
that Bitcoin made when it went from $1
to $10 but I don't think so I think that
those moves could be discounted because
they were so inconsequential in terms of
actual value that you can't look at it
you have to look at what see how the
software it was like he's speaking
nonsense right now so kicked him off
he'll be back in a second but when he
comes back we'll talk about kind of my
thought process behind why I think
Bitcoin will do do so well but as I said
I actually I'm a believer that gold yeah
a lot of people a lot of people thought
that the institutions were gonna be the
next people in to take the market to new
levels and I never bought that that was
gonna happen I mean other than a few you
know Bitcoin type funds the real
institutional money was not gonna get
into Bitcoin I mean these guys won't
even get into gold you know I mean if
they don't want to buy gold I mean I
kind of denied I go to buy Bitcoin so
and now that Bitcoin has collapsed as
much as the market on the way down you
know Bitcoin is actually month this
month February is a horrible month for
stocks
you know Bitcoin has actually down a
little bit more so there was no safety
in Bitcoin gold you know gold is up
during this month so gold is acting like
a safe haven it's acting like a store of
value Bitcoin is acting like another
speculative asset why would anybody want
that I mean what's the point of buying
that so I don't see the institutional
demand coming in to Bitcoin and I don't
think there's a lot of more of
individuals coming in I think by and
large most of the
doctors have already adopted it I think
you know you got some people who are
putting more money in but I don't really
see a lot of growth in people that never
bought Bitcoin deciding now that they're
gonna buy it I think we've kind of run
out of the new buyers I mean there's
some but at this point there's a lot of
people trying to get out there's a lot
of people who bought a lot a Bitcoin uh
you know when it was that in that period
from two hundred to a thousand and I
think had a lot of I think that's when
some of the big money came in I don't
think some of the big money was buying
it when it was a dollar or five dollars
or ten dollars I think most of the
people that were buying it that cheap
have already gotten out I mean there
could be some that still have it but I
think a lot of those guys hit you know
hit the bids a long time ago with most
of their Bitcoin but I think there's a
lot of bigger money like the wink of I
or some of these other way so a Peter
comes back I'm gonna get him to hear out
what the thesis for Bitcoin is coming
out of the financial crisis and we will
talk about either believes that or not
sorry Peter listen yeah so here's here's
what I want to do when we come out of
this financial crisis just like in 2009
and 10 when everyone saw the
quantitative easing coming and they were
worried about the devaluation of the
dollar
they ran into gold right and obviously
gold did very well from kind of end of
2008 beginning of 2009 through 2011 when
it hit the all-time high yeah I am with
you that I actually agree same things
gonna happen here massive quantitative
easing people are gonna run into these
safe-haven assets or sound money
principles that's why I think gold and
Bitcoin will both do well the only
difference between the two that I see is
you have the Bitcoin having occurring in
about 50 days and so it would be like at
the end of 2009 or 10th or in the 2010
as everyone ran to gold 50% of all of
the gold miners shutting off so 50% the
new supply just goes away making that
scarce asset even scarcer what do you
think well first of all well first of
all I don't think Bitcoin qualifies as
sound money number one but number two
even if half of the gold miners shut
down it really is not gonna make that
much of a difference
because the incremental supply of gold
every year is very very low I mean gold
gets its value
from the gold that already exists I mean
the this the increase in the supply of
new mining maybe adds one percent to the
gold market so it's really the supply
and demand of the goal that's already
here and all the gold that's ever been
mined is still here we have the gold and
that's that's our goal supply and and so
Bitcoin the the annual increase in
supply is bigger I mean each year now
the the impact of the mining in Bitcoin
has a greater impact on supply and so
even if they cut the the mining in half
the supply of bitcoins would still be
growing faster than the the supply of
old but I think when it comes to Bitcoin
what's more important is not gonna be
the supply but the demand you know
there's always demand for gold you know
lots you know half of it is used in
jewelry so we're waiting for Peter to
come back for remember check out black
five.com slash pump you can go and
deposit Bitcoin ether G USD etc and earn
up to eight point six percent interest
at black five.com
yeah I'm good so it's so gold so there's
all kinds of real world demand for gold
in industry and then you have central
banks that are going to be buying gold
for monetary reserves and then you have
the investor demand but there's this
demand there Bitcoin only has demand
from one source and that's people who
want to speculate on the price going up
and I think if a lot of people no longer
want to speculate on the price going up
because it's been going down and they're
losing money there's no demand you know
what are the reasons that Bitcoin gained
a lot of popularity is after 2011 the
price of gold went into a bear market
for many for several years and during
that time I think a lot of the gold bugs
were you know you know up frustrated but
then they saw Bitcoin digital gold
supposedly going up where his real goal
was going down and so while gold wasn't
going up Bitcoin had the the party to
itself and it was like see were better
than gold
but now the gold is going up and in fact
it's going up while bitcoin is going
down people are like okay now I can buy
real gold I don't need Bitcoin anymore
because actual gold is going up I don't
need this substitute and so I think the
demand is gonna go away and so I don't
think it matters about a reduction in
the increase of supply if we have a
collapse and demand
what's your Bitcoin worth because it's
you can only use Bitcoin it's only if
somebody wants to buy it from you
because they think the price is going up
but if all the people think the price is
going down then nobody's gonna want to
buy it everybody's gonna want to sell
and who's gonna do the buying
there is nobody so the price is gonna
implode I mean Bitcoin any day I mean
you've seen days just one day this month
the price of Bitcoin was down by like
50% like almost overnight it can go down
by 90 percent overnight the idea I mean
it could just implode there's nothing to
stop it
and so you're taking incredible risk
when you own Bitcoin you know is it
possible I will agree that it is oh man
when he comes back we're gonna see what
he agrees with he's about to say some
wild stuff hold on hold on one second
yeah I was saying I think it's possible
that Bitcoin can make another run to the
highs or maybe make a new high but I
think that is a low probability outcome
I think there is a much greater
probability that we're in a bear market
and we're nowhere near the bottom and so
you know I don't think the risk reward
is there and I think if you want to
gamble on something going way up I think
like silver you know at twelve thirteen
fourteen dollars has a better chance of
going up five or ten fold than Bitcoin
and I think it has a lot less risk it's
not going to zero
I think mining stocks which are very
speculum assets they're not safe havens
like gold but as far as speculative
assets are I think mining stocks if you
want to buy something can go up five ten
times twenty times I think junior mining
stocks for your money or a better gamble
than Bitcoin so if you want to gamble
and take a lot of risk
there's better place
for Bitcoin if you don't want to gamble
if you wanted to play it safe you got no
business in Bitcoin there's nothing safe
about it you know so you can't compare
it to gold I think gold is a lot safer
than any fiat currency you know over a
longer time horizon right a year to your
five years but that's not true about
Bitcoin bitcoin is more volatile and
more risky than any fiat currency out
there and anybody who thinks differently
it's just people I agree with you that
gold is safer than most currencies and I
also will agree with you that gold is
more stable but also that means that the
lack of volatility works on both the
upside and downside so it drew down 12%
right when it goes up it's gonna go up
however much percentage the difference
is that Bitcoin has some of the same
Somaly principles but it drew down 50%
right but when it goes up it goes eyes
going well if that's the case I wasn't
blast went down huh it's up 70 yeah
that's because 12 months that's because
in the year before that it was down 70%
so you Bitcoin crash from 20,000 down to
3,000 you know and so then it wrapped
he's gonna get so frustrated that he
keeps coming out right when right when
he's getting excited and Jose keeps
putting gold prices and Bitcoin prices
on the screen perfect yeah I mean you
you can argue that bitcoin is not in a
bear market right it is in a bear market
by definition and it's a volatile asset
I will give you that I mean as a trading
vehicle if you want to trade it yeah you
could get in and out of it it's very
volatile it's a good it's good for
trading but it's in a bear market and I
don't think that rally means anything I
mean it wasn't you know you you you you
talk to me when we're at new highs talk
to me what bitcoin is above 20,000 but
you know I don't even the I doubt it
agree with you that it's not that 40 hmm
I agree with you that when you hold it
short-term it's incredibly volatile
right
but over long periods of time it's
proven to be a very well performing
asset and I think that the self with
quantitative easing and the having is
gonna be amazing for Bitcoin over the
next 18 to 24 months because there is no
long term with Bitcoin it goes back 10
years 11 years but you can't you can't
jet you can't drive any conclusions
about how it's gonna perform bitcoin was
not around before the last financial
crisis so this is the first economic
downturn crisis that Bitcoin has ever
experienced so there is no precedent we
have no idea because there's been no
historical precedent for how Bitcoin
would respond in a recession in and of
Stockmar in a bear market because it
hasn't seen that it's it's too young its
lifespan has been too short so you don't
know you can't say the long term there
is no long term with Bitcoin it's all
short-term the one thing I will admit to
you is in the next 18 to 24 months
Bitcoin has to shine or it won't fulfill
the promise that it has right this is
the perfect setup for Bitcoin for gold
but if Bitcoin doesn't perform then
that's when people will start to say
bitcoins not what everyone said it was
right but let's say you wait for that
let's say you and black 5 calm / pop
unstoppable domains calm / browser tax
bit calm / invite / pop go check them
out
Joe is going to have a field day with
the memes here while we're waiting
Phelan so people have to realize right
now that if what you're saying is true
is bitcoins got to put up or shut up
over the next year year and a half
you have to realize it if it doesn't do
that and you hold the entire time you
lose everything is you're not gonna be
able to get out because everybody is
gonna want to get out then and there's
gonna be nobody to get in so that's why
people need to make sure right and that
you would have to agree everybody needs
to look at how much bit when they have
and ask yourself this one question if
I lose 100% of this am i totally okay
with it am i fine if I lose all the
money I have in Bitcoin and if you can't
answer that question yes then you got to
sell down your position to the point
where you can answer yes to that
question because even if it goes honest
I don't think it is a million dollars
you can still be rich even if you sell
half your Bitcoin now I don't disagree
that people should look in their
portfolio and understand that there's a
very binary outcome to Bitcoin either
it's worth a lot more than it is today
or it's worth next to zero right but I
don't think that people are confused by
that in most cases I think people
actually have sighs that real
appropriately in their portfolio we
don't have his silver it wasn't
delivered tell them we don't have it
yeah go ahead it was a question we you
need to get some more Bitcoin your are
you gonna buy more Bitcoin going into
this going into those many Bitcoin I
lost all my Bitcoin and you never sent
me the hundred dollars worth it's just
as well I would have lost that too are
you gonna buy more going into this
quantitative easing me I don't have any
how am I gonna buy the Bitcoin no but
will you buy some no I'm not gonna let
anybody else get out I'm not gonna be a
maakad all right when he comes back
we're gonna end this cuz the video keeps
screwing up but he's having too much fun
here let's see when when he comes back
real quick
they'll be back here in a second why
he's worried about if his silver got
delivered I don't even know how is
anybody we don't even have the silver
yet some guys trying to pick up your bed
over my help
delivered to my house all right listen
video keeps screwing up so I don't want
to keep you for I don't want to keep you
for too long since the video keeps
screwing up but we're going to do an
audio only
no no no we're done we're done okay but
here's the thing here's what I'll say
okay you and I both agree on what's
gonna happen with quantitative easing
and the devaluation of the dollar and
many other fiat currencies where we see
eye to eye on all of that I can see and
actually agree with you that gold will
do very well
over the next 2-3 years right just like
it did coming out of the 2008 crisis the
only thing I think we disagree on is
will Bitcoin do well it also right I say
yes you say no and we'll see what
happens but I think 75 80 percent of
this thing we actually agree on and then
it's just fun to you know [ __ ] on
twitter and jab each other I think it's
possible that Bitcoin could do well but
not in the long run so even if it does
do well over the next two to three years
is still a bubble it just means that's a
bigger bubble and it's eventually gonna
pop but I do think looking at the chart
and looking at how it's been trading I
think it's more likely that Bitcoin is
already a pop bubble and I don't see it
reflate into new highs so I think it's a
bear market and I think any rallies are
opportunities to sell and you know and I
think for people who only have Bitcoin
if you only have Bitcoin and don't have
gold would you agree they should take
some of their Bitcoin and buy gold with
it they don't have any they just have
been coin
no you're selling you're gonna make it
oh you you're selling your silver right
now how much do you believe in precious
metals I'm not selling my silver goal I
got it I got somebody coming over to my
house to pick up and silver II bought
they would deliver to us alright listen
because I appreciate you doing this this
is a ton of fun we're gonna keep doing
this throughout the the entire financial
crisis yes right you know it doesn't
need any physically delivered Bitcoin
when Peter uh as we get through this
financial crisis Peter and I will
continue to kind of jump on these
hopefully we get them some better
internet down there no I don't know what
the hell's going on with his Wi-Fi but
we will continue to do this as the
financial crisis continues to develop
but I think Peter and I see eye to eye
on 80% of this stuff we're just gonna
eventually convince them that brian is
just as important as port
yo is gold you used a phone next time or
Skype when you gotta get better Wi-Fi I
use Skype it works fine it's this it's
this thing that we're using all right